hey this is a wild wild story
yesterday trump crony who was convicted
and then pardoned actually by donald
trump roger stone
was served
lawsuit papers
while on the air this is a really really
wild situation roger stone
served lawsuit papers during a live
radio interview
notorious republican dirty trickster and
trump advisor stone had a radio
interview interrupted by a process
server audio was posted to twitter by
former federal prosecutor ron
phillipkowski
we're going to take a look at that video
while roger stone was live on air this
morning with realtalk933 st louis doing
an interview about 2024 he got served a
process server served by a process
server with the january 6th lawsuit this
is really something else take a listen
let me ask you you know you you've said
before that trump should run again but i
think lately you said it's imperative he
run in 2024. is that right
yeah i've kind of there's been an
evolution in my viewpoint um i really
you know politics three and a half years
is a lifetime
uh sin least
and
so now it starts to get he starts to get
distracted you can tell something's
going on and i really did not know
um
if hold on a second i have a practice
server at my front door about to serve
me in the latest lawsuit i i'm going to
take this live on your radio on your
right oh he smokes
wow good morning sir how are you
oh yes a civil court in the district of
columbia
ah yes
it's still a fraud doesn't matter thank
you sir appreciate it
all right i've just been served in the
genius
lawsuit
live right here on your radio wow
tomorrow's news today
tomorrow
big this is a big big stack of papers
which is good because we're out of
toilet paper today
[Laughter]
quite a funny guy huh oh my gosh oh my
roger
oh my god uh you know it's uh like i
said it's law fair it's harassment
yeah so
this is a civil suit um maybe it'll get
some money out of roger stone but i have
to tell you
this guy has really shown over the last
few years he is a slippery guy
and he ends up somehow wiggling out of
every problem
remember when i interviewed him a few
years ago he said i'm never going to be
charged no way of course he was
ultimately charged he was convicted and
subsequently pardoned by donald trump i
mean the guy really is like a parasite
on the political system and it's a civil
suit maybe this will lead to some
financial consequences for him but quite
frankly i'm feeling pretty done
imagining that roger stone is ever
really going to face consequences and
there's sort of a two there's two
stories there
one is how have so many morally bankrupt
and despicable people
how have they become so powerful and
prominent insiders to the american
political system that's one question and
there are many answers to that including
that the system itself attracts these
folks by its very nature there's a
systemic structural answer to that
question
but then the second part of it is
by that very same nature of attracting
those people and putting them into
positions of power
many of them end up unscathed
on the basis of the things that they do
in carrying out
uh their henchmen activities within that
very same political system so very
interesting to hear no doubt roger stone
served while on the air
but i i am sort of beyond imagining that
this guy is going to really face serious
consequences one of our sponsors is
nebia who have developed the most
impressive shower head i've ever seen it
was designed by former nasa engineers
who spent years researching how to save
water and what they created the nebia
bimon spa shower uses 45 percent less
water than a traditional shower head but
with an 81 percent more powerful spray
and they do this by using atomized
droplets that rinse soap and shampoo off
faster than any shower head i've ever
used i installed nebia by moan spa
shower in my bathroom at home took five
minutes to set up i've been using it for
about a year
i'm in and out of the shower way faster
because of that powerful spray but again
it's helping the planet and your wallet
by using 45 percent less water than a
traditional shower head the nebia by
moan spa shower starts at just 199 but
you'll get 10 percent off all nebia
products when you go to nebia.com pacman
and use the promo code pacman the link
is right underneath this video